hello Berlin for three years garishness
has worked as dw's us correspondent in
Washington now he's reporting from the
German capital and informing our
international audience about life in
Berlin if I get city is great and I came
with great expectations after Washington
in New York I thought this must be the
next great city outside since April he's
been based in the heart of Berlin's
government district garrulous writes a
weekly column that appears in both
English and German on DW calm it covers
all aspects of life in the German
capital everything from politics to
culture epidemiol in is a real dream
destination for many people were there
from your chiro or London they want to
come to Berlin because it's not just the
center of political problem is culture
lifestyle parties and clubs hot club sat
yet Berlin is a bit raw and unfinished
to the things bond that makes for
exciting contrasts so I hope lots of
people will join me on my forays through
the city fleece loves to explore the
city on his bike he plans to make
cycling in Berlin a subject of a future
column today he's headed for the east
side gallery a beloved attraction here
tourists can find brightly painted
remains of the Berlin Wall but this
summer fleece made a sensational find he
rediscovered parts of the wall that had
been all but forgotten I think about us
you think all the stories about the
Berlin Wall have already been told but
that's not so at a party someone told me
I work for the waste management company
olivet and we have lots of pieces of the
wall at our landfill more than 150
authentic segments HT sick mentor
jarrell found these segments between
heaps of trash pieces of the wall are
now collectors items but in the days
after the iron curtain fell these were
hauled away and used as dividing walls
DW reported the story quote something
after the wall fell no one was
interested in North they wanted it gone
today it's worth a lot everyone's crazy
about the wall i buy pieces of the wall
and display them it's a flourishing
trade so it's crazy that so much of the
wall is still just standing around
unsold bajwa one [ __ ] off the hob state
isn't just interested in Berlin's
tumultuous past he also reports about
the here and now for example from Kreutz
bec this multicultural district in the
heart of the city is a popular place to
go out there's an interesting story
waiting around every corner and it's a
great place to meet new people you'll
nice job my column is called Berlin 24-7
so I'm always on the move of course I
have to go to the bag I'm once in a
while people expect that I think it's
cool too but if there are so many great
night clubs in courts Berg and freedom a
sign I think all through Berlin actually
it's a thrilling adventure what I want
to take my readers on from clubbing to
high culture his next stop is the
concert house on jean demand mark's
square Garrosh nice and a friend are
here to see the world's top youth
orchestras at the young euro classic
festival
wendys musica thank you can listen to
music my heart skips a beat music is my
passion i studied music i come from a
musical family Berlin has so many music
venues orchestras and opera houses it's
full of music and that's my life con
musica contest is mandating classical
music concerts are among garish Lisa's
favorites who knows maybe this one will
provide the inspiration for a future
column
you